tenemos nueve pelotas que se ven
exactamente iguales sin embargo una de
estas pelotas es más pesada esta pelota
es un poquito más pesada no crees que es
muy pesada sin embargo no podemos
distinguirlo por simple pesaje en la
mano vamos a requerir algún instrumento
y el único que tenemos a la mano es esta
balanza si usamos esta balanza cuál es
el número mínimo de veces que tendremos
que usarla para saber cuál es la pelota
más pesada piensa en su respuesta los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y en un
momento más les daré algunas pistas
suponiendo que pasaron del vídeo y que
lo intentaron por su parte tal vez
algunos llegaron a pensar que se pueden
usar tres veces o cuatro sin embargo les
voy a decir que se puede con solo dos
veces que pensemos estas pelotas
si no lo lograron los invito a que
vuelvan a pausar el vídeo y piensen cual
pudiera ser la posibilidad o cuál sería
la forma en la que con solo dos mensajes
logran saber cuál es la pelota más
pesada
otra vez supongo que pasaron del vídeo y
que lo intentaron o que ya sabiendo que
son dos lograron saber cuál es la pelota
más pesada
lo que podemos saber es que cada vez que
use en la báscula puede empezar dos
tercios de las pelotas dejando tres
fuera y la segunda vez podrá expresar
dos tercios de las que te queden dejando
una fuera y con ello sabrás cuál es la
pelota más pesada siendo te emociona
ella crees que puedes lograrlo vamos
todos el vídeo una vez más e inténtalo
sino a más adelante lo trabajaremos
juntos ok entonces trabajemos este
ejercicio juntos para que lo logremos
resolver en 2 pesajes les mencionaba que
si dividimos en tercios podemos pensar
dos tercios dejando uno fuera con ello
lo que haríamos es tomar este primer
bloque de 3
y un segundo bloque de tres y digamos
que empezaremos este primer bloque en
este lado y este segundo bloque en este
lado por lo que pudiéramos decir que
nuestro primer paso fue comparar tres
pelotas con otras tres pelotas
presionado tres del otro y dejaremos
tres fuera de aquí sólo podemos tener
dos resultados
que esta balanza se quede igual
lo que significaría que las tres pelotas
del lado izquierdo pesan exactamente lo
mismo que las tres pelotas del lado
derecho y con ello nos diría que
entonces la pelota pesada se encuentra
en este otro bloque
estamos de acuerdo sin embargo si estas
pelotas no fueran iguales pues habría un
lado más pesado
un lado
más pesado
y con eso sabríamos de qué lado se
encuentra la pelota más pesada vamos a
ver qué pasa cuando son iguales cuando
son iguales significa que entonces en
este tercer tercio se quedó la pelota
más pesada si nosotros tenemos eso
entonces quitaremos las pelotas que
teníamos en la balanza y pondremos una
de estas pelotas en el lado izquierdo y
otra de estas pelotas en el lado derecho
dejando un afuera
si hacemos esto tenemos dos posibles
resultados
pensaremos entonces una pelota
y una pelota de aquí dejaremos una más
fuera que fue esta tenemos solo todos
posibles resultados que nuestra balanza
se quede igual es decir que ambas
pelotas pesen lo mismo lo que
significaría que esta tercera pelota que
se quedó fuera es la más pesada y
colocaremos que la otra pelota
es la más pesada
o también tenemos la posibilidad de que
uno de estos dos lados sea más pesado
más pesado
y por lo tanto tiende a bajar si
nosotros sabemos que el lado es el más
pesado bueno pues con eso sabremos
directamente qué es la pelota más pesada
habremos
cuál es la pelota
pesada
y estamos claros ahora vámonos con el
otro ejemplo qué sucede cuando un lado
fue más pesado pusimos este tercio de
este lado pusimos este tercio de este
lado y uno de ellos fue más pesado
digamos que fue este lado
el lado izquierdo entonces descartaremos
todas estas pelotas y haremos
exactamente lo mismo que hicimos hace un
momento empezaremos una pelota de este
lado otra pelota de este lado y
dejaremos un afuera
entonces en nuestro segundo paso
haríamos
la comparación de una pelota contra una
pelota dejando otra afuera y aquí sólo
podemos tener dos resultados que creo ya
saben por dónde voy puede ser que esas
dos pelotas se queden exactamente
balanceadas lo que diría que tienen
igual peso o que uno de esos lados sea
más pesado y se vaya para abajo
en caso de que las dos pelotas se
mantengan iguales y nos indiquen que
tienen el mismo peso pues entonces
sabremos que la que se quedó fuera es la
más pesada la otra
mientras pesada
o si estas dos pelotas alguna de ellas
me lleva la báscula hacia abajo
indicaría que con eso podemos saber
sabremos
cuál es la pelota pesada
y esto es sólo un principio general en
el que nos indica que a veces solo nos
dan la posibilidad de pensar dos meses
por cada oportunidad dos posibilidades
como aquí tenemos la báscula 12
posibilidades para pensar en cada una de
estas oportunidades y justo acabo de
decirte cómo puedes lograr saber con
esta división de dos tercios cómo
encontrar la pelota más pesada este tipo
de preguntas luego las hacen más
complejas a veces te dicen cuántos
movimientos vas a necesitar para saber
cuál es la de la pelota más pesada si
tienes
19 27 pelotas y en las entrevistas no
usan mucho aunque a veces les gusta
hacer un poquito más complejo esto y te
dicen qué pasaría si solo tienes
ocho pelotas te eliminan uno y con esto
lo que quieren es hacer menos obvio que
vas a necesitar
vivir en tercios ahora tú ya sabes cómo
hacerlo te acabo de decir como y te
invito a pensar en dos cosas
justo te acabo de dar los ejemplos de
qué pasaría si tuvieras 27 pelotas o si
tuvieras solo 8
con este principio que te acabamos de
decir seguramente ya puedes desarrollar
la intuición y puedes ahora resolver
cualquier derivado de problemas como
éste espero haber sido clara y que este
vídeo te sea de utilidad